انطلاق موكب الامير الحسين
والاميره رجوى الان بعد اتمام يعني مراسم
عقد القران بنشوفهم الان في الموكب
بيتجولوا فيه شوارع الاردن راح يمروا على
سبعه اماكن او مناطق وتحديدا اصلا في الاف
الاردنيين متجمعين بانتظار هذه اللحظات
ومنتظار تحيه الاعريس
والعروسه طبعا هذا الموكب من التقاليد
الملكيه وهم الان بيتجهوا من قصر زهران
حيث تم عقد القران الى قصر الحسينيه اللي
حيشهد الحفل الكبير اللي مدعو عليه
1700 مدعو طبعا الان الموكب في العلي
العلم العلم الاردني طبعا
محيطه بالسيارات لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات